we've got a related question about
volume this one is uh
b to the fifth the question is do you
think that
junk volume is real or is all volume
productive
that's a good that's a good question and
i think that there's um
i think that there are a couple
different ways to answer this
so i think the practical answer is that
junk volume
is real i think a slightly less
practical answer is that
volume is going to do something the
question is more like
is the additive effect of additional
volume going to be noticeable
or is it going to potentially be
counterproductive
um you know you
impose a stimulus on your body it's
gonna do
something um you know on
like the microscopic cellular level like
at least something is going to be
different from doing that eighth set
instead of stopping at the seventh
it may not be particularly large or it
may be like
a small effect that's negative because
maybe you've like
exceeded now your ability to recover
from that session
or recover as adequately but
i think the the term junk volume at
least to me
sounds like it has the implication of
like this extra volume isn't doing
anything
and i think on just a pure physiological
level it's doing something
it's just a question of whether it's
enough to really notice or whether it
would
be beneficial or potentially detrimental
and so i think on a practical level like
yeah like junk volume's a thing um
if you're doing you know if you're doing
like 13
13 sets in a workout instead of 12 like
did that 13th set for a given muscle
group
do enough to really make much of a
difference eh probably not
uh or like let's say theoretically you
do like
four or five really hard sets for
an exercise and then you you know cut
the cut the load by 50
and then do a triple to end with
technically that's more volume
but like that the last set is going to
be so [ __ ] easy it's not going to do
anything noticeable um see i i
like i think practically junk volume is
a thing but i i think that
um you should you should recognize
everything is doing something it's just
more of a question of whether
the effects are going to be noticeable
or not wasn't it you who
mentioned the concept of like hard sets
as a means of of quantifying volume or
am i
getting mixed up um so i got the idea
from nathan jones
um he wrote uh an article for
for at the time string theory back in
like 2014
i think a long time ago um
and yeah so he he is who i got that idea
from
and then i think i'm probably the person
who's popularized it the most
but credit where it's due that was
that was his concept that i ripped from
him shout out to nathan
shout out to nathan so yeah i think
that's kind of a
that conceptually jives really well with
your explanation there of like
it's not that the other volume doesn't
count but like if you're really cutting
to the chase and talking about like
what volume is making really substantial
meaningful contributions
like that's a nice way to operationalize
it i think